[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo marca de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
daniel hablando daniela qué pasaría si
se va a mcdonald's de colombia yo creo
que muchos esperarían el grito al cielo
y pues yo creo que lo pegaron en rusia
no porque ya avisó esta empresa que se
va definitivamente ese país sí señor yo
no sería una de las que pegaría el grito
en el cielo pero de vez en cuando es
bueno al lábaro pues mire este fue uno
de los primeros símbolos del capitalismo
que llegó a la unión soviética justo
después de que cayera el muro de berlín
en 1989 raúl un poquito de historia para
recordar lo que ha sido mcdonald's más
de tres décadas después y tras la
invasión a ucrania este gigante
estadounidense suspendió temporalmente
sus actividades en rusia y hoy ya
anuncia que puso a la venta
definitivamente su negocio en ucrania si
mantendrá suspendida la operación por
seguridad pero seguirá pagando a los
empleados y es que hoy en día el
mantenimiento de la operación en estos
dos países le está costando a la empresa
unos 55 millones de dólares mensuales
que tan grande danny es la operación
rusa de mcdonald's
más de 39 mil restaurantes en todo el
mundo en rusia operan 850 con más de 62
mil empleados la firma dijo que está
buscando un operador ruso que les siga
pagando y que asuma los negocios allí
entretanto calculo que esta decisión va
a impactar sus estados financieros en
hasta 1400 millones de dólares entonces
qué va a pasar lo que sí está pasando es
que el trigo se dispara en la bolsa por
el freno de las exportaciones indias la
guerra dura el precio de los contratos
sobre el trigo en chicago que es el
mayor mercado de futuros del mundo sobre
todo agrícolas subieron subió hasta un
6% este lunes después de que india el
segundo productor más grande del mundo
prohibiera las exportaciones del grano y
sus precios internos alcanzarán un
máximo histórico veamos los 12,47
dólares que hoy se pagan por un bus el
que es una unidad de medida del trigo
son el precio más alto desde marzo en
medio de las preocupaciones sobre el
suministro mundial afectado por la
invasión de ucrania
un día está raúl bastante afectado por
estas olas de calor que dañan las
cosechas no solamente de trigo y es una
situación que se repite en otros países
eeuu parte de francia y también en irak
vamos a ver con melissa chávez cómo está
la situación en este último país
un país golpeado por tres años de sequía
irak ha sufrido una caída drástica en
las reservas de agua según el ministerio
de agricultura están muy por debajo del
umbral crítico nuestros recursos
hídricos están debajo de lo normal y las
importaciones desde el río éufrates son
actualmente de un 30% más bajas de lo
que son en condiciones normales entonces
tenemos un déficit de reservas y de
importación acordate no hay las
autoridades y los agricultores temen por
las cosechas de arroz ámbar una variedad
que es ampliamente utilizada para
preparar platos tradicionales para
sobrevivir estos cultivos deben estar
sumergidos por lo menos cuatro meses
hasta su cosecha si hay escasez de agua
pero se debe a la ausencia de una
planificación adecuada por parte del
ministerio y la ausencia de tecnologías
modernas para desarrollar los sistemas
de riego las cosechas de arroz drenan
cerca de 12 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de agua durante el periodo de
cultivo por esta razón este año el
ministerio de agricultura lo limitó y
pasó de 35.000 a sólo 1000 hectáreas el
país deberá optar por la importación a
pesar que la agricultura representa el
20 por ciento de los puestos a nivel
nacional a dónde vamos a ir qué podemos
hacer siempre hemos vivido en esta
tierra tengo más de 76 años desde que
era niño he estado cultivando arroz
richard valverde y
sólo conocemos el cultivo de arroz a que
es la única fuente de subsistencia de
camps acción en la misma situación se
encuentran los agricultores de trigo
quienes han visto reducidas sus cosechas
a la mitad a esta crisis se le suman las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
que ha disparado los costos de
producción y como resultado los precios
de los alimentos dejando a todo el
mercado agrícola amenazado
y lo que también está pasando anís que
la economía de perú se está recuperando
una buena noticia para ese país tiene
una buena noticia para américa latina el
crecimiento en este país suramericano
fue del 3 84 por ciento en el primer
trimestre de 2022 esto comparado con
igual período de 2000 21 el departamento
de estadística atribuyó este resultado a
la fuerte recuperación de más del 50 por
ciento del sector de alojamiento y
restaurantes como resultado por supuesto
de la flexibilización de las medidas
restrictivas anti kobe de los sectores
que por el contrario se contrajeron
fueron la pesca la minería e
hidrocarburos y también el sector
financiero danny que nos trae como cifra
el día 39 mil 500 millones de dólares
estas fueron las ganancias de la estatal
de arabia saudita aramco en el primer
trimestre petrolera ella casi se
duplicaron frente al año pasado por
cuenta de los estrepitosos aumentos del
precio del petróleo y también hicieron
esa compañía mire este dato que
interesante esta compañía ya superó a
apple la semana pasada como la firma más
valiosa del mundo en bolsa danny gracias
como siempre por toda la información de
economía en directo américa nos vamos
directo
y parís